hey folks unpaired Davina and here today
on gamespot we're talking about gears of
the storm enjoy to me is Kao milker the
production director of the game as well
as Brett offered the lead game designer
hey Brett hey Kao thank you so much for
being here how you folks doing Kurt
doing well yeah hey Kurt things are
going great
thanks for having us what are you
bringing to here's of the storm to
celebrate this five-year anniversary I
know you just okay oh that there's the
players are getting portraits but is
there anything else being added to one
put that up yeah so we're really excited
that the next hero coming to the Nexus
is one I think the lot of players are
familiar with it is May from overwatch
so our our latest tank coming in is May
and she has a really fun kit and I'm
sure Brett can talk a bit about here too
how did you come to the conclusion of
making made a tank in this case
it's actually kind of funny we we were
working on me for a while now and we had
a couple passionate designers that loved
her and overwatch and I said do you
think that we can take her kit and turn
it into a tank because we were looking
for a tank we've been wanting to bring a
tank now for a while and so she's got
all the cold all the slows she's really
good at like disrupting enemies and like
you think we could just tweak a few
things and and turn her in from an
assassin like she kind of isn't
overwatch more into a tank style for
Heroes what was it like translating that
moveset like you just touched on you
Billy this little things don't bring up
ice walls but what was it like taking
that and trying to implement it into
play style it's difficult I would say
that most heroes coming in from all the
other IPS they're all they all have
their own challenges like how do we take
these different game styles and bring it
to heroes for me and a lot of the
overwatch heroes themselves it's like
we're taking a first-person shooter
where they have full control of their
camera and everything else we're trying
to bring that nice laid it into it
the 2d hero's camera on the isometric
view so I think the biggest challenge we
had there was how do we how do we make
her feel like the made from overwatch
without making her feel over powerful I
guess the sake of things a lot of we've
gotten a lot of criticism in the past
for some of the overwatch heroes are
their mobility and they're they're fast
they're always shooting and they're kind
of hard to catch right and so we really
wanted to take a step back and say how
can we really explore this cool new
direction with an overwatch here with me
and like make her sturdy and make her
stand in the middle of a fight and say
attack me instead of like um how are her
ability is going to remain the same or
like little eyes an overwatch player be
able jump in and understand what I can
do with her how he'll that totally her
entire ability set is pretty much coming
over from overwatch of course we've made
tweaks to it she has a couple new things
that overwatch doesn't and we've moved
some things around her um her heroic her
ice wall and overwatch or sorry her
Ian's overwatch is now her heroic in
heroes so and her Blizzard or heroic
that's an overwatch is now her cue and
heroes cool
so we've got we've got everything there
so if you don't know the hero or if
you're familiar with her and overwatch
you're gonna instantly build a jump in
with her engineers that's amazing is
there gonna be any kind of crossover
reward so say as an overwatch player I
mean Amy I do play both but if I if I
were to play an A in here's of the storm
will I be giving a skin in overwatch by
any chance is there is there that type
of thing or is it too soon to say or
yeah well in the past we've done a
couple really cool crossovers with
overwatch and I think those are always
really fun for both heroes players and
overwatch players this time there isn't
a crossover with meso makes it gonna be
coming into two heroes with nothing on
the other side and overwatch but I think
it's something that we'll keep talking
to the overwatch team about and seeing
if there are opportunities for us to do
meet events or to bring players back and
forth across the games like I said it
was really fun when we did that before
yeah I would love to do it again - of
course and it's an ever-evolving
experience which is you know yeah so
trying testament of itself which kind of
goes into some of the next things I want
to talk about
like Nexo mania - so next I mania is
back which which is pretty amazing
because those are really exciting really
cool like all-encompassing of that that
happened what was the choice for next
Romania
it's just statistically to bring it back
the team loves it was one of the funnest
events that we've ever put together our
artists love creating for it that we get
to play with color palettes that you
don't normally see video production team
gets to make cool videos for it and it's
a lot of fun like it's it's really what
heroes in the Nexus is all about which
is kind of these crossover of like how
crazy can we get with some of the skins
and and and like showing players how
neat and how different they can be
but still play exactly the same so it's
one of our favorite events and we were
super excited to go back to it we pulled
the team like we do most the time now I
was like what event do we want to do
next as a team like what the fans want
what do we want and this was definitely
the next one on the top of the list so
we're excited to bring it how is it
going to you differ from lesser well
it's actually going to be very similar
so if you played the first next minute
you're gonna see a very similar pathway
we're bringing back the same structure
where you'll get to choose your champion
at the beginning of the event you know
you'll go down your pathway doing quests
and getting rewards through that
champion and at the end we'll give you a
whole bunch of stuff for completing that
we also have another new announcer
coming with MC tombstone so if you
remember El Guapo you'll get another fun
wrestling announcer which being in these
rooms like as a developer and hearing
these voice actors do this is not
something I'm just kind of but it's so
much fun and they have so much passion
doing it that I can't even like if you
ever get a chance to go watch videos of
voice actors doing it and you're
actually really into the product that
they're doing the voice for it's so much
fun to geek out especially for like
wrestling especially to and like it's
like this everything is larger-than-life
to the nth degree and like I remember
distinctly the original trailer for next
Romania and just the entire thing just
being so who's happening and wobble just
it was incredible so I mean really
excited as you guys are doing that's
with that one go back to me for a sec
I can't forgot that ask this but how do
you lure is so important and the Ebola
played the Nexus and all of these things
is just so fascinating are you able to
tell me how me and her way into the
Nexus well I can say that if you're
playing the game right now you might
have noticed some snow storms appearing
here and there and as an adventuring
climatologist may is interested in that
kind of phenomena so I wouldn't be
surprised to see some other storms on
the on the horizon I also want to go
back and just briefly talk about you
know the five years scope of this game
and you know both of you have said that
you've been a part of this for close to
seven years and it is an ever-evolving
experience and having seen it myself a
few years back and then jumping in and
out over time there's always like the
core thing that makes here's this storm
and then you've the exhilarating part of
his be able to come back and see what's
been added with here's a big things and
new abilities what do you what would you
both say to any newcomers who are
interested in joining back in the ears
of the storm and especially five years
later of the game existing is now I know
of course like now is always kind of
like that's time but well how would you
guide a new person into into something
that's been growing like this for so
long some of the decisions that we made
in the very beginning about about the
game that we wanted here is a storm to
be are still things that I think are
making the game really approachable for
new players everything from these really
short game times you know we still have
20 minute game times that people can
just kind of jump in and get a good feel
for it and then jump into the next game
and it's not really this time commitment
time you play you know in an hour you
can get in three games of Heroes which
is always really appealing but I think
as we've continued adding things to the
game we've obviously now there's like
this menagerie of Heroes but what that
means for players and I think what what
here is a storm really is a love-letter
for Blizzard games and Blizzard
universes you know first and foremost I
think that's something that's been
really appealing to me new players it
was well worth people can jump in and
they can find a hero that they know from
across the blizzard multiverses here and
they can they can kind of jump in and
like like Brett said there's a new
character coming in like May we've done
a like worked really hard at making sure
that may still feels like May and that
the abilities and stuff even though
we're translating it to this MOBA game
and
this isometric view and everything a
different control scheme that it still
feels like the character that you know
and love and so so much of what we've
done with the game like hero by hero is
try to capture both the fantasy and as
much of the gameplay feel of each of
them as we can and I think that's a
really entry point for anyone coming
into the game to kind of find that hero
that they if they're familiar with or
that they cross paths was paths with
before whether it was as something that
they played or something that they
fought against and now you can kind of
jump in and pick up where you left off
yeah I think I'm just gonna say I think
that's really telling cuz when I first
started playing here's the story I came
from playing lots and lots of World of
Warcraft so I was able to immediately
pick an array of characters and kind of
almost have a familiar sense of how my
rotations worked and how I would be able
to apply those into that game so I think
that's a really good point especially
it's certainly a different game as Brett
said earlier from overwatch here's a
storm but I think that familiarity of
just understanding the powers is a
really really good point now as we
approached and I really must ask how
have you all been faring at home while
also making this game okay you go first
a bit really interesting like you know
it's been three months now that we've
been working from home but we pivoted
within a matter of days at Blizzard to
going home and I think it's something
that it has a company we hadn't really
done a lot of before and it's been going
surprisingly well and I think we're all
extremely fortunate in this industry
that we do something that we love and
then it's also something that can
translate into being able to do it from
home like we are now so largely this has
just been we kind of carried forward and
we're still all working like there's a
lot of obviously challenges with
communication and collaboration I think
that's probably the hardest part is this
is a creative endeavor and so a lot of
the spitballing and really cool idea
sharing we do back in the office is a
little harder to do in this in this
medium here but overall it's been going
really well we've been patching all the
games and making tons of new content and
having new heroes like may come out and
working on videos and announcers and I
kind of everything's been carrying
forward so I think we've been really
lucky and and the game is still making
awesome stuff which is like the part
that I have the most fun with so yeah so
I feel super lucky that
to just kind of keep going here yeah but
you Brett have you been doing I'm alive
let me free get me out no it's been
amazing actually
I had never been able to work from home
doing almost anything I've always done
in the office and so this was kind of a
it was a difficult transition to the
point especially as creative and as a
design lead for the games like I'm so
used to bouncing around people and
throwing ideas off of them and stuff
like that and so getting used to doing
that through slack or through WebEx
meetings was was definitely a challenge
but after a couple weeks it's all gone
and stride and to be honest I think for
the most part like I'm much more
productive here than I am at the office
just because I can go to the kitchen and
get a sandwich I can come back and eat
and then if I work it past an hour or
whatever like I can always be on if I
need to be and I can turn it off when I
want to yeah and a lot of freedom that's
come with it which is really amazing
so we'll see we'll see what the future
holds it would be nice to be able to
it's cool the blizzard can see this as a
chance to test what work from home would
be like and then hopefully evolve the
way that workforce I think it's going to
evolve the way the entire world's
workforce changes as we go forward but
yeah I agree and I think it's I think
it's incredible coming from you know
news and press and video side it's been
a curve for us but seeing
game developers and folks like
yourselves manage to pull these things
together and put it out is is incredible
so good work dudes that's all the time
we have today but I just want to say
thank you again Kao and rat it's a
pleasure being able to talk to you guys
brought all this jazz I guess that's
before we go when can we expect may in
the game and when is next in media too
and I haven't you can check both of
those things out right now on PTR and
they both will also actually hit the
live environment next week fantastic
sweet thank you guys again so much for
being here I hope you continue to do
well and eat the unicorn most
marshmallows and all the wonderful
things you guys do and then behind the
curtains of the use of the storm alright
be on the lookout for more here's the
storm content here at GameSpot once
again i'm kurt you see you later
[Music]